hey you guys
me again flickers of fear time got a
really weird one for you today
finally getting around to doing some
terry gilliam i don't think we've
actually talked about any terry gilliam
uh
movies on any of our shows which we
really need to rectify
maybe we should at least do maybe we did
brazil i can't remember
uh but we definitely need to do time
bandits because that's actually my
favorite terry gilliam
movie but this one right here is his
2005
film tideland now it's really
interesting if you guys remember a while
back
when i reviewed the 1990 weird ass movie
the reflecting skin and
when i was reviewing that tideland gets
compared to the reflecting skin
sometimes so much so that if you look at
the tideland wikipedia page
it actually has like in the other
sources kind of section at the bottom it
even has a link to
the movie the reflecting skin because
the themes of them are similar
so when i was going to do the review on
the reflecting skin which i watched on
to be
i noticed that 2b also had tideland so i
was like oh man i should do that because
that's terry gilliam and that's
one of the few movies of his that i
haven't seen so i put it on the list to
do and i finally got around to watching
it so this was actually my first
viewing of this movie like i said i've
seen most of his other movies
several times but i had never seen this
one i
apparently just like kind of forgot it
existed until i was doing the reflecting
skin review but i'm glad i finally got
around to
watching it now this movie when it came
out
and i didn't actually remember this this
movie got
really really wildly divergent
critic reviews a lot of critics
really despised it i mean so much so
that i think it was uh
richard roper that said something like i
hated this movie it's like i was gonna
walk out of the screening and i never do
that
and um some just people said it was
awful and it was just like this
kind of creepy and exploitative and all
of this other stuff but then
on the other hand when it played at like
some um
festivals and stuff it actually got a
lot of accolades so this is definitely
one of those movies
that you're either gonna love it or
you're gonna hate it now
if you're into terry gilliam i don't see
any reason why this would offend you
uh in any way if you're not into terry
gilliam
this might be like uh what the [ __ ] did
i just watch
kind of situation this is a little bit
different than some of his other movies
but it does have a lot of his
hallmarks in it like there's like a lot
of surrealism and things of that nature
now i will not lie this is kind of a
difficult movie to watch and there's
like a lot of
disturbing [ __ ] in it but i think the
reason maybe
that a lot of critics hated it was
because i don't
i'm not gonna say i i don't think they
got what he was trying to do
but i think they were looking at the
movie from
the wrong perspective maybe and i'll
kind of get into that in a bit
so i guess what had happened prior to
this was that
terry gilliam had been trying to make
the man who killed don quixote
they i think they kind of got into the
production and then they had like a lot
of
issues with it nothing no one's fault it
was just kind of like
nature you know flooding and things like
that kind of [ __ ] up the
thing and i think there were so many of
those things happening that the
production eventually ended
up getting canceled after which terry
gilliam then went on to work on
uh the brothers grimm which was kind of
a bigger budget like studio film
and apparently he didn't have like a
real good experience with that um he
felt like it didn't really come out the
way he wanted
you know he had a lot of control that
was taken away and things of that nature
so i guess with tideland
he basically wanted to make something uh
completely independently and he just
wanted to do exactly
what he wanted and that's pretty much
exactly what he did so
this was a british canadian
co-production
and they actually shot it in
saskatchewan
and then it played at some festivals it
did really well in europe it seemed like
and actually the only
the only country weirdly i don't know
why this is the only country weirdly
where
this was like a box office success was
japan
now the reason it only got got a very
very limited
theatrical release in the us i guess um
thinkfilm
that uh distribution company picked it
up for a u.s release
but then for whatever reason only showed
it at like nine theaters i think that
was the most
in the whole entire country that was the
most i'd ever played at so it made
something like
sixty thousand dollars because they only
should they just like botched the
distribution
uh terry gilliam was kind of pissed off
about it and like i said
even most of the critics that saw it
really really seem to hate it and i like
i said
uh you know everybody has their own
opinion about [ __ ] i just i kind of feel
like this movie maybe
is in kind of maybe the same boat as
maybe lars von trier there'd be
people like that where they're making
movies that maybe are you know skirting
some kind of uncomfortable
issues and some people don't really like
that or don't like the way that he's
approaching it
let's put it that way so i can see why
people maybe
didn't like it but i i think they were
just maybe looking at it
uh from from a perspective that maybe he
didn't intend
so you know we'll we'll get into that so
this is actually based on
a novel by mitch cullen now
interestingly the author of the novel
was a huge fan of terry gilliam and
before the book was published
he apparently sent uh like an arc like a
you know an early copy to terry gilliam
not like for him to make it into a movie
but because he just wanted like an
endorsement or like a quote that he
could put on the cover or something like
that
but terry gilliam liked the book so much
that he's like well [ __ ] i'm gonna make
a movie this is gonna be my next movie
so that's uh what he ended up doing so
the story of tideland this is about a
little girl
named julyza rose and
she lives with her two uh
junkie parents played by jeff bridges
and jennifer tilly they are both
heroin addicts and
very early on in the movie her mom
dies of an overdose and
her dad whose name is noah decides that
he's going to take her
on a journey uh he has this thing where
he wants to go to
yutland he has the interesting thing
about this movie is that
jelisa rose's entire world view
is has been shaped by her parents who
are
neglectful not outright abusive although
i would argue that her mom is probably
like emotionally abusive because one
minute she's like i love you and then
the next minute she's like
what did i say about eating my chocolate
you little [ __ ] it was like it's that
kind of thing
so you know it's not a good situation
but the dad has kind of like all of
these
fantasies about things he's gonna do so
i feel like the daughter
since this is the only life she's ever
known um has kind of grown up around
this and is kind of like bought into
this sort of fantasy world to an extent
so after the mom dies uh
noah and the daughter kind of have to go
on the run because they don't want to
you know they don't want to get caught
because of you know drugs and whatnot
so they end up getting on a bus and
going back to noah's
mother's house which is kind of this you
know
creaky old abandoned house like out in
the middle of the prairie i think it's
in
it's i think it's supposed to be in
texas but like i said they filmed it in
saskatchewan
and this is very much where the
similarities between
this movie and the reflecting skin come
in because you have these
massive wheat fields they might have
been like even shot around the same area
i'm not entirely sure
but these massive wheat fields with like
these kind of like creepy abandoned
houses
and i think there's another um there's
another thematic kind of similarity too
because in the reflecting skin if you'll
remember
all of these kind of tragic things ensue
kind of based on one child's
perception of the neighbor as
a vampire this is kind of a similar sort
of story
but not quite as dire as that this is
almost kind of like the flip side of
that because
july's a rose's character lives in this
horrific from an adult point of view the
life that she lives is
horrific like no child should have to
grow up i mean
she is shown in the movie
getting um her dad's you know heroin
like getting the needle and putting the
heroin
in the needle like from the spoon and
everything and giving it to him so like
getting ready
but from her point of view this is not a
bad thing or a good thing it's just
part of their life she doesn't know any
different and she doesn't like she's not
upset about it she's basically like oh
you know daddy's going on vacation and
she knows he's gonna like space out for
a few hours and she has to like
entertain herself
so the theme of this movie is almost
kind of like
how children can use
their imaginations arguably maybe even
madness
to deal with situations that
particularly from an adult point of view
are horrific
so and that's essentially what she does
because even though from our point of
view
her life is horrible she does not seem
to see it that way because she has
she's so mired in her own fantasies that
everything for her is it's almost more
like wonder
you know i mean even things that are
scary so
her and her dad end up going to this
house that used to belong to
noah's mom now noah's mom has since
passed away
and the house has been abandoned so they
basically just kind of squat there
now they haven't been there very long
before noah the dad
also ods and he basically dies in the
uh in the chair in the front room now
it's arguable how long it is before i
mean julyza rose
as i said she's very very much fantasy
she's a very fantasy prone
child now does she know that he is dead
i don't think she does know at first
because she's used to him just kind of
spacing out for long periods of time
because he's a heroin addict
and so at first she doesn't think
anything unusual
i think at some point as he like this is
horrible but
as he begins to decay i think she does
realize it but she's so used to
seeing everything through the framework
of her imagination
that she like recasts it as something
not necessarily something positive but
something that's not scary because i
think the whole theme of this movie like
i said and i
that's what i meant when when i said
that
maybe critics that thought it was
exploitative or
lurid or whatever we're seeing it from
our point of view yes from our point of
view
um everything that happens to her in her
life is terrible and it's
you know this terrible kind of [ __ ] her
parents are terrible uh they neglect her
the like the way they've raised her is
horrific
but she does not see things that way
because she has this whole framework of
her imagination and i think the whole
point of the movie is that you're
supposed to see
things through her eyes and
almost kind of like admire her
resilience
and it's almost kind of and i'm not sure
if terry gilliam intended this or not
but i think and i saw another analysis
of the movie that said this
as well that said this might be that
what he's implying
is that sometimes madness might be
preferable to the reality if the reality
is horrific enough
so it's like even though you know her
life is
awful like from our point of view since
she doesn't see it that way she sees
everything with this kind of childlike
sense of wonder
even though it's an invention you know
you could argue that maybe that makes
her
happier that makes her strong um i kind
of feel like that's where he was going
with that
so her dad dies and uh
basically just like sits in the chair
and then one day when she's
out playing she um i forgot to mention
too that she has her only friends
at first are these she has these little
uh like little barbie doll heads
she has like four i think there's four
of them and she they're just the heads
and she has them like on her fingers
sometimes
and she has different voices for every
single one of them
and each one of them is sort of like a
representation
of part of her psyche i guess the one
that she talks to the most
is named mystique and uh mystique
is very sophisticated and she has kind
of like even though jalisa rose herself
has kind of like a southern accent
um mystique has kind of like a very twee
like upper crust british accent
so we're led to believe that mystique
represents
what she aspires to be like she wants to
be this sophisticated
uh you know lady like royalty or a
princess or something like that
and she has like other ones there's one
called glitter girl and there's one
she has a couple other ones that
represent other parts of her nature like
one of them that's
you know very timid and very cowardly
which is kind of like
that's where she puts when she gets
afraid of something she kind of
can can talk to that one and like say
you know oh everything's going to be
okay so that's kind of how she deals
with that situation so
she's out and about playing in the
fields one day and she sees this woman
wearing um what looks like morning
clothes really it's just kind of like
this black which i said that also kind
of reminded me
a lot of the reflecting skin too and at
first she thinks this woman is a ghost
because like i said she lives
in she lives in this complete and utter
fantasy world
but it turns out that this woman is not
a ghost this woman is her
neighbor who's this woman named dell and
she's blind in one eye
and she's real not uh she's a little
cranky and she's really not
uh too down with this kid like poking
around all the time
so through dell she meets dell's
brother whose name is dickens now
dickens
is a mentally challenged young man i
think he's supposed to be 20 21
something like that
i don't know if he was born that way or
if
because he explains that he had uh
epileptic really bad epilepsy
and he has like scars on his head so
they said they did like an operation to
try to make his epilepsy better even
though he still has it but it's like
it's improved
so i don't know if they're implying that
they botched
the surgery that they were doing and
that's what you know that's what made
him the way he is or if he was just like
that to start with
but it doesn't really matter so i think
the most controversial part of this
movie
is the is the friendship that develops
between her and dickens
because it does shade into
i don't want to say a romantic
relationship and like i said people are
going ooh because it's like pedophile
you know like pedophilia and stuff
but as i said you have to approach this
as if you were looking at it from a
child's point of view they're both
childlike i mean she is an actual child
and he is a man who has the mentality of
a child
and you know they they say oh i love you
and we're gonna be husband and wife and
she makes a joke about being pregnant
because
uh you know this is this is sad but it's
like she's
starting to run out of food at her house
and so her stomach is growling
and she's convinced now because she
kissed dickens that now she's pregnant
and that's the baby inside and oh it'll
come tomorrow but that's what i mean so
it's just kind of like she doesn't know
how the world really works so
the relationship between them even
though it seems like i said from our
point of view it seems super creepy
because he's
you know twice her age or more but
it's it's just very innocent and nothing
happens between them like they kiss each
other but that's about
it um and she like you know makes
pretend she wears like a little bridal
dress and stuff like that but it's stuff
that like a little girl
would think about someone her own age
because i don't think she realizes
because he acts like a child too
and he is also mired in his own
fantasies
that she i don't think she sees him as a
an older man i think she kind of sees
him as someone the same age as her
because he acts pretty much the same as
she does because dickens
also and his fantasy involves all of
these
wheat fields and everything being like
an ocean and he says he has a submarine
which he is named lisa
which is actually just this old shed
that he keeps all this stuff in
and he said i'm a sea captain and his
goal in life
is to defeat uh the monster shark so he
says one of his main things is he puts
out bait for the monster shark
now the monster shark is actually uh the
passenger train
that goes by like every day so
he puts things on the tracks which he
calls bait in the hopes of
killing the monster shark so like i said
you can see as innocent as he is
you can see how his fantasies are going
to be dangerous to other people because
at one point and you figure this out
later on july's a rose
is before she even meets dickens she's
playing in this overturned bus
uh that's all wrecked and everything
that's kind of by the um
the train tracks and you're you figure
out later on
that that bus was like one of the
pieces of bait that he put on the tracks
to try to get
to try to kill the monster shark to try
to derail the train
but he doesn't realize that that's what
he's doing you know what i'm saying
because he's it's a fantasy world he he
sees it as a monster shark and
he's trying to kill a shark and he's
going to be a hero and so she kind of
like
gets involved in uh in that fantasy with
him so they kind of like start sharing
all their fantasies together
now eventually she figures out sort of
uh that her dad is dead because he's
been sitting there rotting
in the chair and then this movie like i
said this is
this is one of those movies like i said
if you've never seen a terry gilliam
movie or you're not really and you watch
this you'd be like what the [ __ ]
am i watching dell the ghost slash witch
lady that lives next door
she i guess she was either married or
she was noah's girlfriend like
way back in the day uh before jalisa
rose was born
she's also dell is also a taxidermist
she has taxidermied her own mother and
she sleeps upstairs
and so she decides she's going to
taxidermy noah as well
and there's this whole and this kind of
goes along with the whole like child
fantasy thing where july's a rose can't
really
determine i don't know if she can't
determine between living people and dead
people or she's almost kind of like
switched the concepts around in her mind
because of a lot of stuff that her
father told her because her father was
really into like bog bodies and stuff
like that so she kind of got an idea
of these mummies or you know people that
had been dead for
but you know maybe they could come back
someday so i
don't know if she has a complete grasp
of the fact that her father is dead
and especially after dell taxidermies
him
and they keep him in the house and you
know she puts like a wig and makeup on
him and stuff like that and so it's
almost like he's still alive and that
kind of becomes part of her
fantasy so it kind of goes on like that
and then in the end like i said because
of dickens
fantasy about killing the monster shark
i.e the passenger train
you know that probably something bad is
going to happen at some point because
he's
he keeps telling jaliza rosa i have the
secret i have this thing and i have to
show it to you
and then uh he shows it to her and it's
like a whole bunch of dynamite
and you know that he's gonna put that on
the train track at some point and he's
just talking about oh it's gonna be the
end of the world
and it's gonna kill the monster shark
and i'll be a hero and all this other
kind of stuff
and um indeed that is what ends up
happening he does actually end up
derailing the train they don't really
say like how many people die or anything
but obviously it's this massive like
conflagration and there's like wounded
people running around everywhere
and it's really creepy because like at
the end you're led to believe that
probably dickens
dies and doesn't really see because he
has like a seizure
and then um there's like a struggle with
dell in the house and
you know the the mummy of the mom gets
all [ __ ] up and stuff
and so the little girl runs away and
then later on when she sees
the train derail and the huge fire and
she goes down there to look at it
her first instinct is to be happy
because she's like oh my gosh she's like
um you know dickens succeeded
in his he's a hero he killed the monster
shark but then
there's like a woman there and she you
know she was a little bit injured in the
accident but she's so gay and
then she sees july as a rose and she's
uh you know she assumes that the child
was
in the accident as well and uh she's
like you know where are your parents you
know i don't know where they are and
stuff like that so you're going
so at the end you're led to assume that
july rose is going to be taken in by
this woman
and maybe i i don't know if the
implication is that she's going to have
a
normal life because as i said
it's almost kind of like terry gilliam
was saying and i saw an interview with
him earlier when he was talking about
this movie
and he said that he's like i don't
really like
when they portray um you know so much as
like oh children being like victims or
they're scared of everything he's like
children are actually very strong like
much stronger than you think they're
very resilient
and i think what he was trying to get at
with this
was that as horrific as this little
girl's life was
she was not unhappy or even all that
damaged she may have been i mean
madness was definitely uh
you know a possibility but he's perhaps
making the argument that maybe
that's better like maybe it's better for
her to just
vanish into you know this
fantasy that she's created for herself
where she's happy
than have to look at the reality of her
situation
and the fact that he's saying that maybe
that's okay
like sometimes madness is preferable i'm
not really sure if people i mean that
seems like
he's very interested in madness and
imagination that comes out in a lot of
his
movies as far as i know this is the
first time that he's actually
done a movie like this from a child's
perspective though so
like in a lot of ways like i said this
reminded me a lot of the reflecting skin
but
almost like the the opposite of that
because like i said in the reflecting
skin
that boy didn't understand the world
either and he had a whole of fantasy
uh you know based mostly around the
widow you know dolphin blue being a
vampire but that ended up causing a lot
of
misery whereas this is almost kind of
like the opposite where it's like she
has this entire she doesn't really
understand how the real world works
either
or maybe she does but she has decided
that she's just gonna construct this
fantasy world around it
so that everything will be wonderful and
magical and everything like that and she
doesn't have to face
you know all all of the [ __ ] that's
going on around her
so in that way this is a very very
strange movie and like i said
there's some stuff in here that
particularly the the relationship
between her and dickens like i said they
don't
do anything sexual really but
there is an implication that there's
some kind of romantic relationship but
like i said you have to
imagine that even though he's older he's
mentally the same age as she is
and she perceives him as such so it's
like it's very innocent it's not
done i didn't find it you know it's
uncomfortable to watch
but it's not i didn't find it like
creepy or
exploitative or anything like that
because i understood that i was seeing
things the way a little girl
would see them and she doesn't see it
she doesn't really understand
the implications and neither does he so
there wasn't any kind of predatory
anything like that so i wasn't like
creeped out or think it was exploitative
or anything like that
you know so so it didn't bother me but
if that sounds like it's going to be
something that's going to bother you and
like i said there's some pretty gruesome
[ __ ] happens in this like i said
you know there's lots of uh you know
drug addiction
uh you have little kids making a little
kid making up like heroin needles and
giving them to the dad like it's no big
thing
you know those people get taxidermied
and
you know people are rotting and things
like that
so so it's this kind of thing it's very
like i said
it does have a lurid is a southern
gothic
kind of aspect to it so much so
that it's you know it's it's kind of
over the top but in a way it sort of has
to be
because it's kind of showing this is how
this little girl lives and this is why
she's gone to such lengths to construct
this fantasy to sort of
keep from having to deal with it because
why should a little kid have to deal
with
this you know what i mean so it's kind
of like better
that she's keeping herself happy by
you know just building this whole entire
framework
uh around her little doll heads and
around uh
this fantasy that she constructed and
you know maybe that's better in some
situations but like i said this is gonna
be one of those movies that
people seem to either really really love
it or really really really hate it
uh so i'd be interested uh to know what
you guys think about it
as i said this is the first uh this is
my first viewing of it i really liked it
um i didn't find it like i said
offensive or anything like that it's
a bizarre ass movie for sure but it's
terry gilliam so i was kind of expecting
that
um not my favorite terry gilliam i think
that would probably be time bandits or
maybe
brazil but um definitely if you are into
terry gilliam and haven't seen this one
then definitely give it a watch uh it
did get like i said
wildly divergent critic opinions on it
but i do kind of feel like
you know it came out in 2005 maybe
enough time has passed uh that we can
give it a critical reassessment
but i do feel like if you're gonna watch
it go into it
not looking at things from an adult
point of view
i kind of feel like it's almost i almost
want to say this is kind of a little bit
like
maybe pan's labyrinth or city of lost
children or something like that where
all of this horrific [ __ ] happens but a
kid is kind of like
you know that's kind of how they how
they go to like how they deal with
things
and so if you look at it from it put
yourself into the mindset of an
imaginative
child i think it will seem less
creepy you know what i'm saying because
i think that that i kind of got that
that's what the vibe of it was we're
seeing everything from her perspective
even even though it's normal like we're
it's weird because there are a few like
surreal
uh you know set pieces in this um you
know there's some weird [ __ ] with the
doll heads and there's this one where
like underwater like you know where the
inside of the house is underwater and
like the
you know jeff bridges body is like
floating around and stuff so there's
some like that but mostly it's kind of
played like realistic
but you're still even though you're
seeing things the way they would look in
the real world
you're still seeing things through her
eyes like the you know the way she's
talking about things happening
and you know what's going on and stuff
even if you're not always visually
seeing it um in the movie so if that
makes any sense
but if you go into the movie just know
that you have to see things from
a little girl's perspective and this is
how a little girl
with a lot of imagination who had a
terrible life like this
this is how she is choosing to deal with
it this is how you know this is how her
brain chose to deal with it
and i think if you go into it with that
mindset it won't
seem as uncomfortable maybe because
you'll kind of see what tara gilliam
where where he was going with it because
as i said this is a completely
independent production he didn't have
any uh you know studio interference or
anything like that
uh it is based on a book and as far as i
haven't read the book but um i've heard
it's a pretty faithful adaptation
i think that the book is actually much
darker
than the movie uh the movie has a lot
more like of a whimsical
uh you know there's a lot of alice in
wonderland uh you know
references in there uh you know to
rabbit holes and she reads alice in
wonderland uh
you know at some stages of the movie so
it has much more of a whimsical tone to
it even though it is very dark
but as i said some of it goes kind of
like very lurid like a southern gothic
type of thing
but i've heard the book is much much
darker i've heard the book is good
though so i might actually get around to
reading it one of these days and if i do
that i'll do a book review on it and
i'll tell you how much it's different
from the movie
but uh yeah so this is also on 2b at the
moment for free
so if you're into terry gilliam and you
haven't seen it
um please go check it out and let me
know what you thought about it because
this one like i said
this is i love these like love it or
hate it kind of movies because they
always
they always engender like such
interesting discussions um
you know and if you hated it then i i
totally understand that
too i'm not like saying oh you shouldn't
hate it or or you didn't get it or
whatever i would never say that
um so just if you did hate it let me
know if you loved it let me know i'm
really interested to see what kind of
discussion this uh brings up so uh yeah
that'll do it for
this flickers of fear i will see you
guys on the next one
bye